hello everyone
so uh every year here at iit kharagpur
and i'm sure in many of the other iits
also we have this very important piece
of evaluation for the final year
students called the comprehensive viva
now there is a grand event uh
and it's something which often induces a
lot of fear among the students and i
have been
a part of this comprehensive viva both
as a student and as a faculty member
for the past few years so i thought that
i'll
share a few tips with you guys
um
before i uh go on to the tips uh
let me just clarify and uh gives a bit
of disclaimer that in no way my comments
should be taken as the official comments
of the mechanical engineering department
of which i'm a
faculty member nor of the institute okay
these are my personal views alone
something which i have
garnered
as a student
and as a faculty member
all right so i've written down these
points because i have a tendency to rant
without proper notes so
some very common mystic students make
the first and foremost is that
is a mistake they make even before
coming to the viva and that is they
don't prepare well enough now this goes
without saying that this is a very
important piece of evaluation and they
should be preparing well but what i mean
to say is that
uh
well uh let's put this in perspective
you see uh this viva takes place in the
final year so
basically the students are officially
supposed to be uh
to be knowing something like 30 to 40
subjects
well
humanly it is not possible to remember
everything
okay i am a faculty member
i don't remember many of the things
which i teach myself every semester okay
and how am i going to expect students to
remember everything
from those 30 40 subjects it's not
possible so
the most strategic thing that a student
can do
is to prepare well to their strengths
now this is something which almost every
student fails to do they do not
prepare to their strengths
what i mean by that is that every
student has a certain bent of mind and
depending on that they are good in
certain subjects
they should
properly and very strongly revise those
subjects okay suppose someone is very
good in solid mechanics or in fluid
mechanics or
maybe in some subjects of manufacturing
maybe casting forming welding
or something else internal combustion
engines whatever
they should prepare that really really
really well
okay
now
uh
here in
iit kharagpur
in the mechanical engineering department
we have
uh three sections
uh one is manufacturing
one is uh thermal science and
engineering and the other is mechanical
systems design
now
the panels that are made for these
comprehensive fibers consisting of maybe
four five six professors
uh
assigned to each of these panels they
will be like
eight to ten students maybe a little bit
more sometimes
uh so these five or six professors or
maybe four or five professors they will
be evaluating these nine or ten students
now
the way that these panels are
constituted is that
there will be a good balance between the
various among the various sections so
there may be two professors from
manufacturing to professors from thermal
science and engineering and two
professors from
uh mechanical systems design
so that there's a good mixture of
questions that is asked to the students
accordingly it is expected
although it is not officially written
down anywhere that the students
would have prepared
well officially the expectation is that
they would have prepared everything but
as i said humanly that is not possible
so
uh it is at least expected that they
would know something from
a few subjects from each of these
sections
okay so for example when they come
for example this just a as a just a case
that they may have studied something
from casting forming welding and
maybe modern methods in manufacturing
and then from the thermal side maybe
fluid mechanics and thermodynamics and
maybe from
the mechanical system design may be
dynamics and mechanics of solids or some
other combination
now
what happens is that students are so
much overall by the this this huge list
of subjects
that
they sometimes do not
uh
revise at all from a certain section
okay maybe they completely uh overlook
the mechanical system design part or
maybe they completely overlook the
manufacturing side now that's a very
very bad mistake to make okay and it
kind of pisses off some of the
professors who are there in the panel
on the flip side okay so this is one
mistake there's a mistake on the flip
side to it also
sometimes what students do
rather mischievously is that
some sometimes they get to know uh
who which uh which of the professors
will be there in that panel and they try
to kind of second guess
the nature of the questions which will
be asked now this is rather mysterious
okay
i came across this instance of a very
mischievous student who
uh
uh who said that he had really studied
well from a particular topic
and
that topic or that subject
was not taught
by any of the panel members sitting in
that panel including me
so
it was kind of awkward but then
well professors can also be a little bit
mischievous so what we did was that we
asked him
not exactly on that topic because none
of us were teaching that's a particular
thing
so we asked something very basic which
is that the fundamentals of that topic
the student claimed to be knowing
and it just turned out that he didn't
know even that so he ended up getting
very bad marks
so mischievous
mischief can work both ways
now
on a more serious note
students should not try to second guess
what kind of
questions will be asked in a particular
panel rather as i said they should
prepare to their strengths
maybe study properly two or three
subjects from each of these sections
from manufacturing thermal science
mechanical systems design and that way
they will be able to answer a wide
variety of questions
that are asked in the panel
so this is one one aspect
so
another mistake which
students make
is that
they kind of get so nervous that they
very easily give it up
so usually we do not ask questions
which
which are formula based or
which asks you to remember a certain
equation although we can ask some
questions like that but generally we
don't we avoid asking questions like
that rather
what we ask is based on the fundamental
concepts
we will ask a question which will uh
which will
test the student
to apply that concept the general
notions of that concept to a particular
application
so uh
maybe we ask something like
uh
if you want to construct a beam uh
that is that has to be of a rectangular
cross section then uh
how should you place the beam
so the longer side should be vertical or
the longer side should be horizontal
so things like that and that can be
easily answered by
having a very preliminary understanding
of how the second moment of area or the
moment of inertia is calculated
okay
i think i think this is
i mean there are certain kinds of
students who
because of the lack of revision
sometimes or because
they are a little bit too nervous
they
don't try to apply their brain in front
of the panel to try to answer these
questions
and i'm quite confident that if they
were asked the same question maybe over
a cup of tea when they were very much
relaxed they would be
immediately be able to figure the figure
out the answer so uh although it's
easier said than done yeah my advice is
that try to relax a little bit okay we
are not trying to
uh we are not trying to
kind of
extract what you don't know
rather we are trying to extract the best
of what you know
uh again
on the flip side of it
there are certain students
who
will try to [ __ ] their way out of
the of the question so when they don't
know
they will just try to [ __ ] their way
okay now this is the worst mistake that
a student can make
okay and uh
i have uh kind of
themed this
video like
common mistakes that the riotians make
during comprehensive survivors
but this applies equally well to any any
viva for any student whether in iits or
any other institute okay students should
never try to [ __ ] their way out of
the question if you don't know the
answer to a question to a technical
question
say that you don't know okay it's much
much better that way
okay
say you you have not studied it or maybe
you have completely forgotten it you
have no here you do not recall that this
concept at all
come come clean with it okay please do
not try to [ __ ] this is the worst
offense
uh
so
uh i think these are these are the main
things that i wanted to talk about um
i'll just end up with one little
anecdote that i have from my own student
days so this was back in 2008
uh
so i was sitting in my comprehensive
viva fourth year
and
i was asked a question on
some topic of manufacturing i think it
was
something regarding the importance of
riser
and i
mentioned a few points on the importance
of ryzen and then
i kind of lost my way and said something
uh and then one of the professors in the
panel he kind of
very
mischievously said that
evan jyoti i think you have done a very
good decision by changing your dual
degree specialization from manufacturing
to mechanical systems design
well
uh it just so happens that
uh
in a few days from now maybe
so today is sunday on wednesday i am
going to sit in a panel for
comprehensive
along with the same professor
on this side of the table
such as life
thank you